no one had greater expectations for 2021
than kamala harris but her first year as
vice president has not gone
as planned her approval rating hitting a
historic low her staffers keep jumping
ship and she still refuses to address
the crisis at our southern border but
this is this isn't how the white house
wanted the year to go so in a last-ditch
effort to get the vp some positive
headlines they set up a nice cushy
interview with cbs this weekend
but it didn't work if anything it made
matters worse listen
what do you think your biggest failure
has been at this point
to not get out of dc more
i mean
and i actually mean that sincerely i've
talked to some of your former senate
colleagues and they say
you have been given an impossible
portfolio do you think any of this is
fair do you think you're being set up to
fail
no i don't believe i'm being set up to
fail i'm vice president united states
anything that
i handle
is because it's a tough issue do you
think you are judged fairly
i will leave others to to make that
decision
joining me now to react host of fox
across america jimmy fella ditch the
jacket i just my first question for you
jimmy is do you feel like you're being
set up to fail by coming on with me
tonight
well i just want to be clear about one
thing i'm broadcasting tonight from
wapacanetta ohio which by the way makes
you the first sober person i've talked
to in three days but the reason i'm
going without a jacket kp
yes i mean you don't know guapa caneta
i'm going without a jacket because this
is my jim jordan look i'm in his
congressional district right now so i'm
not doing the gym fella i'm doing the
jim jordan but no i don't feel like i'm
being set up to fail uh and neither is
kamala and this is the part that i think
is her biggest detriment as a public
human being like she is a lying
sociopath and i mean that kp when she
says in that interview oh when we first
got into office we weren't allowed to
travel yo joe biden has gone back to
delaware every single weekend of his
presidency and sure he might think he's
still in washington but the rest of us
know he's been traveling okay and this
is no different than the border you know
when she has handled the border uh we
didn't get mad at her because of you
know her gender we didn't get mad at her
because of her race we got mad at her
because the border is a now problem
people are being affected by the
fentanyl coming across the border now
she responded to it by conducting a
study on the root causes of illegal
immigration yo katie if your house is on
fire and you call the fire department
the last thing you want to hear is
you're in luck we're going to conduct a
study on the root causes of fire no you
don't want that you want a truck with
water and she's not sending it which is
why she's pulling behind omicron right
now
well jimmy they've tried really hard to
kind of rebrand her image with a couple
of these interviews all of them have
gone poorly they haven't fixed the
awkward nervous laughing yet and it's
one thing to do these interviews of
rebranding your image when there are
things going right with the
administration but they can't get a win
on anything right now
yeah but that's another lie too is when
she said well we've got to pass
buildback better because that'll get
cost under control you know the
congressional budget office the cbo
scored this bill they found that it
would increase inflation and it would
add to the tax deficit and it would add
to the national debt as well so at a
time when americans are struggling
passing this bill is the financial
equivalent of throwing a drowning man a
sofa and there she is like
there's molaf again we got to pass the
bill and that's why nobody likes her you
know and that's the biggest thing kp is
like what she doesn't get is we're not
mad at her because she's a woman we're
mad at her because she's incompetent
okay there's nothing she can point to
that's a success and this idea that her
defenders okay and that's why she's
being asked that question were you set
up to fail when you're the vice
president of the united states you are
second in line to a job that will never
have the luxury of choosing which crises
you have to tackle and on some level the
people working on her staff have to know
that but the fact that they've continued
to carry on as if this is a race thing
or this is a gender thing it's
embarrassing kp
well when she says it may be a race or
agenda thing and also the the media has
been saying that i mean the interviewer
also made that uh that that statement
basically in a biased question when she
asked her it's like do you remember
president donald trump and how the media
treated him he and as
i recall he was a white male
and he got treated pretty poorly
yeah i mean at this point in the trump
presidency let's think about the poll
numbers here okay biden and kamala are
polling both below 40 percent okay and
that's comparable to where trump and
pence were with the key caveat being
that at this point in the trump
presidency everybody in the media on
earth was pretending he was a russian
asset controlled by vladimir putin at
this point the biden presidency we have
everybody in the media pretending he's
sane and competent come on man
all right jimmy we brought you on for
laughs and you delivered did not set you
up to fail thanks for joining us
listen i just thought this was an
intervention after all i drank at
christmas so thank you bye you're the
best kp
you're welcome hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else